[Música]
Ucrania conmemoró el primer aniversario
del inicio de la invasión rusa a su
territorio durante la jornada se rindió
homenaje a las víctimas de la Guerra el
presidente voló y mirt selensky aseguró
que este es el año de la Victoria y
agregó que le gustaría tener una Cumbre
con países de América Latina
escala la atención diplomática entre
Perú y México la presidenta peruana Dina
boluarte anunció que retirará al
embajador peruano en territorio mexicano
la mandataria acusa a su homólogo Andrés
Manuel López Obrador de intervenir en
asuntos internos de su país
y entró en funcionamiento la mega cárcel
construida por el gobierno de nayib
bukele en El Salvador bajo un fuerte
dispositivo de seguridad las autoridades
se trasladaron este viernes a los
primeros 2000 pandilleros a las
instalaciones que pueden albergar acerca
de 40.000 reos
un cordial saludo Mi nombre es Ángela
Gómez y aquí están las noticias de
France 24 comenzamos Ucrania conmemoró
el primer aniversario del inicio de la
invasión de tropas rusas a las regiones
de dones que y lugansk en la zona del
donbas la jornada estuvo marcada por un
acto conmemorativo en kiev capital
ucraniana precedido por el mandatario
boludo y mircelenski el presidente
ucraniano en una rueda de prensa para
medios internacionales habló entre otras
cosas de estar abierto al diálogo pero
con condiciones un poco más temprano
conversamos con Catalina Gómez Ángel
enviado especial de France 24 a kiev y
nos dio un resumen de los hechos de este
viernes
había temor sin duda y muchísima gente
como lo dijo y lo confirmó el alcalde
había salido de la ciudad sin embargo
fue un día extremadamente tranquilo ya
básicamente se ha terminado este 24 de
febrero Este primer aniversario muy
diferente a lo que vivieron exactamente
hace un año cuando las cinco de la
mañana empezaron esas explosiones Y esa
invasión a gran escala con el temor que
tenían entonces de que el presidente
Vladimir Putin pensaba que en tres días
ya iba a tener el control de esta ciudad
sin embargo actitudes como la del
presidente
que decidió quedarse y dijo que aquí
estaría con el resto de los ucranianos y
les dio armas para que pudieran también
unirse miles de personas y miles que no
tenían ningún pasado militar pero
querían defender el país pues esto hizo
un gran cambio en el país y esto también
lo recordó hoy que cuando hizo una rueda
de prensa con los periodistas muchos de
los periodistas acreditados para esta
primera aniversario de esta invasión a
gran escala hablo de China no fue tan
fuerte como lo ha sido como la Unión
Europea trató de crear puentes con ellos
habló sobre latinoamérica dijo que
estaba dispuesto a ir a hablar con
dirigentes de latinoamérica para
explicarle la situación de Ucrania y
ganar su apoyo y lo mismo hizo con
África también habló de Israel de ese
apoyo que ellos básicamente esa cercanía
que tiene a Rusia y dijo que eso se
refería también a una historia pasada
histórica de Rusia Así que fue una
conferencia de prensa también
sentimental pero en la cual dijo que la
victoria llegaría si sus aliados
europeos siguen apoyándolo la diplomacia
no ha podido parar hasta ahora el
conflicto en Ucrania sin embargo Rusia y
Ucrania sí se asentaron a negociar para
permitir la exportación de grano de los
puertos lo que evitó la hambruna en el
mundo se potenciara nuestra enviada
especial Irene sabio desde harquifan nos
actualiza sobre el tema
uno de los pocos acuerdos ventanas de
luz de la diplomacia que supuso una
tregua un respiro en este año de guerra
ha sido el llamado acuerdo del grano que
se firmó gracias a Naciones Unidas y a
Turquía donde ucranianos y rusos se
sentaron en la misma mesa para pactar el
desbloqueo de los cereales bloqueados en
los puertos ucranianos este fue un
acuerdo firmado en marzo de 2022 muy
importante no solo para Ucrania sino
también para el mundo supuso que se
pusiera un freno a la alza de los
precios de los alimentos que estaba
teniendo gravísimas consecuencias a
también en América Latina y que no
empeorará esa situación de hambruna ya
acentuada por la pandemia del covid 19
por eso Será muy importante estar
atentos a la próximo 18 de marzo las
razones que ese día expira este pacto
firmado con Rusia
y esto ocurre en un momento Precisamente
en el que Moscú se encuentra
particularmente aislada a nivel
internacional y además
ha anunciado que no prolongará el
acuerdo si no se levantan las sanciones
contra sus productos agrícolas en
Argentina viven aproximadamente unos
450.000 ciudadanos a ucranianos o
descendientes esta comunidad convocó a
una manifestación frente a la sede de la
embajada de la federación rusa en Buenos
Aires en rechazo a la invasión de
Ucrania que esta comunidad ha calificado
como genocida natalio cosoy corresponsal
de France 24 en Argentina nos da más
información
Esta es la fachada de la embajada de
Rusia en Argentina y aquí está llegando
esta marcha que se encuentra a mis
espaldas convocada por la comunidad
ucraniana en este país una comunidad que
algunos estiman que podría estar en
torno al medio millón de miembros muchos
son descendientes de pasadas migraciones
a la Argentina y están aquí reclamando
cuando se cumple un año de la invasión
rusa Ucrania por la salida de las tropas
rusas de su país por la salida de Rusia
de Ucrania ya habían comenzado con este
tipo de marchas aquí mismo al inicio de
la invasión y ahora las están repitiendo
otra vez repitiendo el reclamo que se
inició hace un año y en este aniversario
vuelven a traer aquí a la embajada rusa
misión Al iniciar esta invasión en otras
noticias escala la atención diplomática
entre Perú y México la presidenta
peruana Dina boluarte anunció que
retirara al embajador peruano en su
territorio mexicano la mandataria acusa
a su homólogo Andrés Manuel López
Obrador de intervenir en asuntos
internos del país la información con
nuestro corresponsal en Lima Francisco
Zacarías
en un corto pero contundente mensaje a
los peruanos la presidenta Dina boluarte
anunció que decidió remover al embajador
de Perú de México luego de las duras
críticas que el presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador expresó
contra la mandataria horas antes en
rueda de prensa López Obrador llamó
presidenta espuria boluarte porque dijo
que el 85% de la población la desaprueba
y recusó a la oea a la ONU y a los
organismos de derechos humanos de
supuestamente hacerse de la vista gorda
para no actuar amlo dijo que seguirá
apoyando a Pedro castillo y a su familia
Tina boluarte rechazó enérgicamente las
palabras de López Obrador por apoyar El
fallido golpe de estado del expresidente
Pedro castillo y señaló que con sus
declaraciones el mandatario mexicano
viola el principio del derecho
internacional de No injerencia en los
asuntos internos de los países las
relaciones bilaterales entre Perú y
México escalan a un nivel más
confrontacional México desde hace
algunos meses no cuenta con embajador en
Lima y ahora le toca el turno a Perú que
no tendrá embajador en México así las
cosas las relaciones diplomáticas entre
ambas naciones quedan por ahora en manos
de los encargados de negocios y llegaron
a la prisión más grande de América
Latina los 2000 primeros reos se trata
del megaproyecto del presidente de El
Salvador nayib bukele una cárcel con
capacidad de albergar a unos 40.000
presos y La Bandera del mandatario en su
lucha contra las pandillas desde que
declaró el estado de excepción el pasado
marzo de 2022 los homicidios han
disminuido en el país centroamericano
pero organismos humanitarios también
denuncian violaciones de Derechos
Humanos dentro de estas prisiones
marinas ardeña informa
despojados de cualquier rastro de
humanidad así llegan los 2000 primeros
presos a la prisión más grande de
América Latina en El Salvador hoy en la
madrugada en un solo operativo
trasladamos a los primeros 2000
pandilleros al centro de confinamiento
del terrorismo esta Será su nueva casa
donde vivirán por décadas mezclados sin
poder hacerle más daño a la población el
megaproyecto del presidente salvadoreño
nayib bukele tiene capacidad para 40.000
personas su construcción fue criticada
por la oposición señalando falta de
transparencia tras la aprobación de la
oficialista asamblea legislativa pero
las duras políticas de bukele contra las
pandillas gozan de una gran popularidad
entre los salvadoreños que dicen
sentirse más seguros en las calles desde
que declaró el estado de emergencia hace
casi un año las autoridades Han detenido
a más de 64.000 personas acusadas de
pandilleros y las tasas de homicidio se
han reducido drásticamente el denominado
centro de confinamiento del terrorismo
situado en la ciudad de tecoluca
darte en la particular batalla del
mandatario contra la violencia
célula célula estamos eliminando este
cáncer de la sociedad sepan que no
volverán a salir caminando del secot
pagarán por lo que son cobardes
terroristas el país centroamericano
tiene la tasa de encarcelamiento más
alta del mundo si bien la percepción de
seguridad ha cambiado en El Salvador el
costo es enorme para la democracia y los
Derechos Humanos como denuncian varias
organizaciones humanitarias que aseguran
que el gobierno incurre en violaciones
torturas y asesinatos dentro de estas
prisiones
y en France 24 punto com
[Música]